à voisins le bretonneux le conseil
municipal des jeunes sept enfants réunis
en présentiel samedi dernier après avoir
été élu en novembre crise sanitaire
oblige ce premier conseil a eu lieu au
centre sportif les pyramides et déjà pas
mal d'idées ont été évoquées par les 25
enfants pour améliorer leur commune on a
vu qu'il y avait plein de proches
beaucoup de sportifs plein dans vie de
projet sportif un petit peu dans tous
les styles sont des jeunes qui
présentent une candidature qui ont qui
ont un projet qui ont des idées pour
améliorer aussi leurs conditions
peut-être de jeunes dans la ville comme
pour les grands les jeunes se sont fait
élire par leurs pairs profession de foi
campagne électorale dans les collèges et
écoles primaires puis vote une élection
en bonne et due forme qui doit permettre
aux adultes d'avoir une autre vision de
la commune
c'est une force parce que ils voient pas
la ville de la même façon que nous c'est
un lien important parce que nous on a
besoin d'avoir ce lien avec les avec les
plus jeunes
les consulter sur certains domaines
aussi et les jeunes ont plein d'idées
sur lesquels les grands pour elle est
consultée principalement sur
l'environnement mais aussi sur
l'embellissement de la ville ou encore
le tri sélectif mettre des poubelles
pour extrêmement des chiens dans les
villes et toutes sortes toute autre
sorte de poubelle parce qu'il ya toutes
les poules et déjà sont mis dans une
seule poubelle à voisins donc six donc
après c'est à eux de faire le tri et
c'est un peu plus compliqué lille ou
comme ces 24 camarades est donc élu pour
deux ans à n'en pas douter au vu de leur
grand nombre d'idées les jeunes comptent
bien travaillé pour améliorer leur
commune